welcome to continued mug club quarantine
months that's the hashtag and of course
you can enter the promo code quarantine
you get $30 off at laterals credit.com
slash mug club we've decided to try and
serve you as best we can since we're not
first responders we can create more
content than ever and put all of the
content that's usually available
exclusively promote clubbers in front of
the paywall so that you don't feel so
lonely during this month you can get a
lot of kind of calm /schedule to see all
of our live broadcast when we'll be
doing live chat and what you're about to
watch is actually something we do every
every couple of weeks mass Monday where
we'll take on sort of a topical but also
theological issue and deal with it from
a biblical perspective those girls are
most of us here are Christians and let
us know what do you think about these
kinds of programs and if you'd like to
see more of this on YouTube as it's
usually available exclusively at mug
club right now and if you are a member
please do renew because we make zero of
the Benjamins
from YouTube if we were to count on them
to make it rain there wouldn't be any
rain
all right that's not really a dance in
for people those of you watching on the
YouTube we have the free mug club month
going on of course the promo code is
quarantine if you join up at a lot of
calm such mug let me get this stuff
every week every week morning show right
now is special for the quarantine
obviously I don't wanna be doing
two-a-days for the rest of my life
Who am I Terrell Owens no I'm not I'm
not your rubberband man did you know
that he was known as rubberband man
really yeah why is that because he used
rubber bands so body elastics and they
said no ins rubberband man Thank You
minute said I am the rubberband man Wow
to a housekeeper not my not my
housekeeper I can't afford housekeeper
some but I gave the Terrell Owens
endorsed body elastic bands to a
housekeeper of others houses houses
homes
I should probably create my own house
first and get an order that's what we do
this often I think every other Monday
it's been typically a mass Monday LEM
for films in the past
checking on some issues you know as
everyone here is a Christian some people
come from different denominations
different walks if you don't I get it
you're a 2007 YouTube atheist you just
read Hitchens I get it flying ginger was
it Dawkins I remember that monster I
don't know I say monster like it's
Herman spaghetti that's not common but
actually we do want to talk about so
nice to him because it's been making the
rounds on on YouTube throughout the
whole sort of YouTube blogosphere and
you brought this to my attention
audio Wade yeah you said hey I would
like to maybe do a podcast yourself on
explain yeah so the rhett and Link
famous on youtube I think they have like
16 million subscribers right recently
came out did a couple of videos call
about their spiritual deconstruction is
the words yes it's the term it's very
cool yes
so yeah they did a couple of episodes on
that each one about an hour and 45
minutes just going through their stories
of basically how they lost their faith
right
and they came from very different points
of view on that but yeah that's and I
thought that warranted at least a
response well I think it warranted a
response because and I want to be really
clear as a Christian obviously we want
to speak these people everyone who's in
this boat out of love compassion we care
of ours and Christians we all believe
that our worldview is correct and namely
because we also want what's best for
people and obviously creating distance
between yourself and God we don't view
as being best for you know he doesn't
the cry virus he does not need a little
distance now that being said I also
think based on what we will get to some
clips here based on what we've been
watching that sometimes these people
also need to be an electric challenged
not emotionally coddled so I think
that's pretty important and there are a
lot of questions that were sort of asked
that weren't really answered and this is
a big thing that you see the term
deconstruction that sort of the
terminology is used a lot now from these
really sort of the like Freedom From
Religion Foundation I don't know if they
use it exactly but a lot of these places
so just someone leaving the faith yeah
so let's set up the context before we
get into some of these arguments I want
it by the way hear from everyone out
there since this isn't a you know only
mud club right now we're doing a live
chat we've done live chats all week but
in the comments section let us know if
you ever had a crisis of faith or how
you maintain faith or what your
worldview is as a Christian because
sometimes it sometimes I just go oh
that's a different perspective and then
sometimes it dumbfound me I'm itchin but
I sacrifice goats in the temple we did
so before we continue and yeah this
might be a little bit I don't want to
say scholarly I'll still be dick jokes
but let's go for context to the link
explaining it's off the bat why they
left the Christian faith this is when I
adopted what I'm going to call
California Christianity oh boy
to get at what link was getting out here
a second ago
man but not in LA or no even within the
evangelical church I think there is this
sort of because you're in this
incredibly diverse place with so many
different perspectives
you really can't maintain a Christian
faith in a place like this without at
least some sort of realization that
there's a lot of grey it's not about
having it all figured out
it's not about being completely certain
it's about a relationship with Jesus at
this point I was like okay you know what
I think this is probably where faith
comes in you know it makes sense to me
that this might be where faith comes in
because I am sitting here trying to
prove this stuff out but shouldn't I
just have faith first and then maybe
these answers will be given to me by God
isn't this what faith is all about I
mean the whole point is this it's
evidence of things not seen and this is
where la comes into play think about
seeking know la did allow me to ask a
new question almost like it's in that
way why am I still doing this it could
be in the Bible and I'll be honest I
would not have asked that question if I
was in North Carolina you know we were
working out of this little basement
studio and just putting stuff on the
internet and once we started to act our
world got bigger when we started to meet
other creators I remember when we met
that's something I called Buckley the
first time he gave me a hug and I
remember thinking I this is the first
openly gay person I've ever hugged and I
don't know what I know what I'm supposed
to believe about this guy that I'm
hugging but this but and it was a crisis
moment for me cuz you just would just
facepalm um that's true no hugs right
from for meat and let me clarify it
didn't feel right feel from me to render
judgment of him because what I wanted to
do was hug him back and actually mean it
but there was I would I'd been the
belief that I was ingrained with didn't
allow me to
sounds like Riley's
to sincerely hug the guy and I was it
was upsetting yeah and I must been
really hard okay couple things that need
I want to say this as a jumping-off
point this is with a lot of Christians
and by the way no surprise here they try
and cut it off at the past that people
who come from small rural areas for
small Christian towns go to California
or start working in the entertainment
stream they say I know people are gonna
say you went to California and became a
sort of a liberal walk liberal or ever
they say like but that's not what
happened no that's exactly what happened
basically said that any personal
experience with someone of a differing
view point or differing lifestyle
Michael Buckley he was a guy used to do
the show what the Bock remember what the
back that was his like original it was
like tabloid stuff like he wasn't
particularly nice gay guy it was a very
she gay to do some push-ups Oh what the
bog go back that was his cash shrimp so
you just look every single night and say
what the back but lovingly as mad about
you will be more honest you should not
be able to hug this person right and I
mean it and so this is important because
this is often used and and I understand
that everyone has their own sort of
journey and people talk about it this
way but listen you cannot say that you
had to abandon your faith because of
what the faith teaches or what the Bible
teaches or what Christ teaches because
you had ingrained in you something that
was not at all biblically correct this
is really easy go to scripture just
scripture at any point tell you and this
is also used by the way as a jumping-off
point where they say well we know there
are some decent Christians out there who
are pro-lgbt qaa IP by the way notice
they didn't use the full right not
enough but what the insinuation there is
that anyone who is a Christian who
believes in the fundamental roles of men
and women in a marriage in a nuclear
family must hate gay people yeah just
like you can hug someone who is
promiscuous which as Christians we don't
agree with and love yeah normative
Michael Buckley you and your what the
[ __ ] catchphrases not in my house of
worship like this
you were taught wrong are you believed
wrong and you had false guilt there's
nothing in the Bible that would say you
should feel guilty or repulsed by
hugging a gay man out of love and that
is not the reason for it shouldn't be
the reason for converting no and I think
that's a great point to make is that
when we talk about Islam we don't talk
about somebody's teaching on Islam we
talk about the book right and so there's
a lot of we've got someone's teaching
well we don't we don't pick like a rate
of thing yeah well you know what I mean
we judge these faiths by the the text
that they say that they go by sometimes
you're gonna have a misinterpretation of
that and somebody's gonna go off and
form a religion that believes if you can
survive a snakebite you're truly holy
and that's the religion that we're gonna
have and so we're not gonna we're not
gonna put them out and say well that's
Christianity and we're gonna judge that
almost like virtually based doesn't the
Bible say something about not testing me
saying he won't
yeah so I mean I want to make sure that
we're being fair but also for the for
the people out there that are watching
this even if you're an atheist and you
have you have no faith whatsoever
we'd love to hear why maybe you don't
have a faith maybe you've done some
research and you just don't want to but
with these guys what they're doing is
they're putting out stories about their
journey through this process personal
experience yes their personal
experiences and and I think they're
bringing up points that are very easily
challenged again we're approaching it
with love and we understand that people
have crisis of faith and so we're not
beating them over the head saying you're
wrong you're wrong how are you we're
just talking about what they are saying
to everybody else there's a there's a
lot of feel there's a lot of touchiness
to it there's a lot of slow storytelling
that kind of draws you in and there's
nothing wrong with that that's a
personal story for those guys but but
it's very short on let's dive into these
issues on these podcasts at the very
well my main point here is if you
convert from a religion from a faith
because you don't agree with what is
prescribed in that faith well then you
better be sure that it's what is
prescribed and yeah not hugging my guys
not in there yes do you realize I was
since I was 11 years old on the set of
Arthur and I was doing voice work behind
the scenes I was taking sips it was just
it was bad almost my takes of doing
voiceovers were between hugging's of gay
guys
there's everywhere but I think that's
also a danger of keeping young
Christians very sheltered and not along
them be challenged at a young age so
what I see is a your turn about the
personal experience no trumping all when
we're talking about when we're talking
about issues of faith and doesn't all
come down to personal experience and
whether they realize that or not that is
part of the California Christianity
right yeah that they have said that
they're being sheltered in a different
way now yes they moved away from North
Carolina where they said that they felt
sheltered in some way but yeah they are
very insulated there they're also very
insulated in California it's just
different people insulating them right
different beliefs ya know and I think
that's important to note because this
also can be indicative of someone who
becomes a byproduct of their environment
yes because I've known people for
example I did not fit in at my youth
group when I was young or any of the
churches I did not I didn't fit in when
I went to public school which was
Catholic school in Montreal I didn't fit
in with the youth group there was a
Pentecostal youth group at one point
that was a whole different thing that
was the only that was the only church
within a five-mile radius of me at that
point yeah and then of course I didn't
fit in with people in the entertainment
astre so just just because you feel like
you don't fit in somewhere or people
might disagree with you and Hollywood
doesn't mean that you fundamentally
abandon your principles right so I think
we do need to get a little bit more into
why it is that they had these doubts or
what the reasons would be if there's any
reasoning as opposed to feelings I think
that's the next clip we have yeah well
they talked mostly about those reasons
during the first 45 minutes or so of the
interview and it's and it's mostly just
sort of quoting experts or quoting books
that Rhett said in read it you know and
for every single one of those you could
find some PhD who says the exact
opposite so really really the issue is
not any particular evident or piece of
evidence it's obvious that a lot of this
has to do with prestige or at least at
some level some amount of respect right
opens it he opens the his portion of the
podcast was saying I want people to like
me like right off the bat he says that
that's personality it's that about it
they hated me first
I'm rusty on my scriptures yeah they
hate us excuse for you to for example
steal from people's clearly labeled
drawers in the office refrigerator and
if I'm mad say like oh they hated Jesus
first that's not the same thing here I'm
sorry I want to be very clear yeah I
know it's clearly mark I shouldn't use
my middle name to be well let alone just
be with a period yeah I want to be clear
if and I do encourage everyone to go in
and listen to the show listen to their
reasoning but like you said it's not
really any one piece of evidence it
really does come down to the word
experiencial yeah very much so and
there's you know there's something that
we saw in there that he said that we we
found out that there was a lot of gray
when we moved to California and I'm very
puzzled by what he means by gray there
shouldn't be new gray there is gray but
there shouldn't be new gray based on
geography different approach to gray and
your friend shouldn't change but
Christianity doesn't almost the reason
for religion the reason for faith is to
often deal with the gray yeah right and
so we talk about this there the Bible
does have you know I've said this a lot
to you guys in our offline conversations
we should be as we should be firm with
the Bible is firm and we should hold it
loosely where the Bible holds it loosely
right we should make sure that we're not
firm on things that the Bible is not and
then the opposite if the Bible's loose
on it we shouldn't be firm and so there
are places where specifically he ends up
talking about the lgbtq+ community and
that's how he says it and saying you
know that this is one of those things
and I'm like well the Bible is not gray
here the Bible has never been great
about what sin is and is not right it's
very clear on that otherwise it would be
we serve a very capricious God who can
kind of change his mind whenever he
wants to on what sin would be but how
you treat those people is also not gray
right those people is me as a sinner is
much like oh that's not great right you
treat each other with love just like
your brother is your neighbor and your
neighborhoods your brother it's like
everybody is that close together and
that's very very easy to see so I'm
wondering what gray are you talking
about because now that was the one thing
that you brought up the more saying what
and I said Californian gray what sudden
gray what change kinda like Mitt Romney
where Mitt Romney went from being
choice this whole political career -
then pro-life there's no Hana second
what changed because you were always a
Mormon you always claim that your your
religion was what determined right is
what educated your politics
so then what changed yeah it's not like
you were saying well I was a secularist
and then I learn you know I someone came
knocking on my door off got off his
bicycle with a helmet and shortened
middle-management shirt and a tie and
brought me in the Book of Mormon and
then I said I'm pro-life
no no what changed and so for me it's
what changed we're all of a sudden
there's this great and if what you would
use as an example is well now it was
gray because I had to hug a gay guy and
it felt like I should be repelled by him
well that's not great that's your own
issue and I think the danger here is
applying your own hang-ups and your own
issues and offering that is any sort of
prescriptive advice to people out there
who may be struggling with their faith
because that is not gray yeah yeah
that's a lot of the reasons that
personal people that I've seen leave the
faith or say that they're atheist is
that they say all these things like
people are hypocrites and they're liars
and they do these things that are in the
inside of the Christian faith and you're
talking about people right then you're
not talking about the faith you're not
talking about Jesus you're talking about
the people that are inside and we know
that they're that way right so yeah yeah
okay well let's uh let's go over here we
have another clip to get to and then
we'll come back and sort of dissect this
a little bit more I understand that it
is unreasonable to expect Christianity
to be a set of scientifically verifiable
principles it is a faith implying that
some sort of believing without seeing is
involved and more specifically
Christianity is a relationship with
Jesus and relationships are not well
defined or experienced scientifically
however I don't think it insignificant
that the deeper I have dug into
Christianity with a thirst for the truth
the more difficult it has become to have
faith in fact for me it has become
impossible and that was kind of the
reckoning for me when I jump ship I
didn't jump to another boat
I jumped into the water and I pulled my
wife and my children in with me again I
want to know we started digging started
seeking for the truth and they talk
about how the conversion happened after
they move so they try to cut out of the
past you know not because of California
why did you only start digging for the
truth once he moved to California yeah
why weren't you taking for the truth
when you're North Carolina when you were
shoring up by Christians when you by
your own admission let a men's Bible
study yeah where you was were you lying
to them cuz I would obviously assume
that someone in a leadership position of
a Bible study is seeking truth and I
think they could be warding it
improperly but a lot of this is designed
to discredit everything they believed
before as though that we're never
seeking truth no no you had a different
opinion that was formed often I can't
necessarily say this with certainty
because of your environment whenever he
was leading that he was like trying to
he is how these questions and he was
trying to look to two knowledgeable
books and stuff like that so he did have
like questions about it but yeah like
you're right he didn't really jump ship
until well we all have questions about
that I don't have doubts in my faith why
it's a struggle that's why almost the
almost the entirety the Bible is
designed to at least help you with
answers and your struggle with withouts
right and and and the environment also
includes the books you're reading right
yeah so those those are things that
you're putting in your life it's the
choices that you're making the things
that you're surrounding yourself with so
you can surround yourself with books
that are saying the one thing surround
yourself with things that are bolstering
your faith as well as challenging your
faith I would recommend both right yeah
well so he said something about science
and this is something that we talked
about just a little bit but he said the
deeper I dug into science the more I
couldn't kind of buy my faith so to
speak right I'm paraphrasing kind of
what he was trying to say there and you
know some people will make some some
pretty easy mistakes when they look at
the Bible they'll they'll make the Bible
out to be a science book when the Bible
never claims to be a science book right
and it doesn't discredit what the Bible
says about scientific matters if it does
address them right but it's basically
saying like look guys this is not like
cellular biology this isn't freshman bio
101 that we're trying to accomplish here
we're trying to the God has obviously
chosen stuff to communicate to us that
he feels is very important but wait you
and I were talking
this and really the crux is there are
wonderful like it's pillars of the faith
that that have different opinions on
some of the science discussions that
happen within Scripture sure but I had a
question my church has something called
great questions and people can come in
and ask any question it can be a theist
it can be people who seek you know I
have a deeper relationship people who
are on the fence like whatever it may be
we've had everybody come in and this
person asked me they said you know I
don't believe in evolution can I still
or I do believe sorry in evolution right
so they believed in evolution
scientifically taught can i still be a
christian and I just it floored me and I
I had this response to it and I headed
again when you and I started talking
about it before the show like I wanted
to kill this question and there was a
reason for it I understand that it
sounds like it's over the top but I said
look when you get to heaven right and
you're standing before God do you think
he is going to say did I do it in six
days I don't think that that's where you
start it doesn't mean that that question
isn't something that we can't discuss
and have a really interesting
conversation about but at some point
with that we have to understand that
certain things are very important
they're crucial to the job in certain
things are debatable and that's okay we
can debate about those things and still
be Christians Yeah right and so on I
think that's I'm wondering what he's
talking about here with sign with
science because there are plenty of
scientists out there that are Christians
and there are plenty that are not
obviously right and you can listen to
what both of them have to say and then
you can test what they say all the
Christian Scientists aren't wrong all
the other scientists aren't wrong
scientists and I think that that does
illustrate that debates like this are
not ultimately decided by the evidence
it's ultimately decided by what you
bring to the evidence which is what your
worldview is right and in the amount of
who you trust what you trust if your
baseline trust is in the Bible or if
your baseline trust is in the world
standards that's gonna make the
difference yeah so the specific evidence
this is about the age of the earth I
believe in the young earth but that's
not something that is a decisive issue
as far as right what I'm saying is like
it's I can't prove that to somebody who
has decided to not believe that right
just like I can't prove that the Bible
is true and there are some
I do want to be clear they never really
bring this up there are some things that
can be proven that are undeniable by
people across the spectrum yeah let me
address this first there's a lot of
deferring to experts right that you see
and he just put the law out citing a
whole lot well you know I read this book
or I heard this person and I understand
there's a value in experts I understand
that particularly like I am someone if
we know in this in this program I always
try to seek out the best or whatever
whether it's whether it's someone who's
doing something technical on the editing
side whether it's someone for research
whether it's someone who's really good
at actually finding and securing a
location security like we really try and
find the best folks so I believe me I
understand the value in particularly
being advised by experts that being said
you can't simply adopt the opinion of an
expert because they're an expert and let
me kind of explain it to you this way to
bring it something simple I've talked
about this what's Brazilian Jujitsu or
any kind of combat sports now doing it
quite a long time and the reason I bring
this up is if you play basketball
now many people who play basketball you
know at a I don't know local park get to
play with Michael Jordan right right now
many of you even Charles Barkley Scottie
Pippen the thing is in Brazilian Jujitsu
I get to do that like I've actually
gotten to hit the mats with people like
marcelo garcia Boucher these guys who
are multiple time world champions the
Michael Jordan's of this sport either
come in and do seminars so you get to
experience really really brilliant
people the best that they won't have to
offer and I have at some points perform
certain techniques and someone causal
don't do it that way do it this way like
why would I do it that way this will
just look at my medals do you trust me
there's some times you have people that
way they're not very helpful they go
look at my medals this was a very
specific instance where someone's will
look at trust me I know do it this way
the very next tournament this guy went
on who was a former world champion got
smoked by doing it the way I was doing
it beforehand from another expert
today's expert can be tomorrow's
ignoramus because this idea that that
scientific progress you returned with us
is linear right it's not always
sometimes there's a double back six
flags man yeah Thomas Kuhn talks about
this in the structure of scientific
revolutions yeah it's essentially there
the myth of scientific progress is it's
not some kind of hockey stick graph of
like everybody was idiots for a long
time and then now we have this explosion
of technology really there's every 50 or
a hundred years some new paradigm just
because like an entirely new paradigm
has taken on I mean one illustration of
that is the coming Ice Age and the 1970s
we narrated it and now it's global
warming yeah no its climate change again
because that's true that's true
I just yes just as an illustration I
[Laughter]
just as an illustration of the whole
idea of a paradigm shift and that's what
happens in science just like any other
displayed it happens quite a bit and by
the way these issues were argued by
early Christians to keep in mind this is
important like what's will bring the
neutral bring us to our next clip yeah
which will bring us to our next clip
here pretty soon where they talk about
how all societies have some kind of
moral good core well not only is that
not true but guess what not all
societies have sought out knowledge with
the same importance okay that's why you
have people who had aqueducts you have
people who would use the wheel and yet
people who hadn't even domesticated
horses here because didn't encourage
people forward pre fruitful multiply it
to explore the questions of the universe
right that's why the early early
scientists were Christians and I
understand we can say that's a different
period in time and now these people are
actually trying to halt science I
understand some people might have those
arguments out there but there is no
historical there can be no historical
denial of early scientists who were
deeply Christian and philosophers by the
way a lot of them and there can be no
historical argument about the impact of
the Bible the impact of Jesus Christ and
for me when we talk about history the
easiest thing when you read the early
it's sort of an too early persecutors of
Christians this to me was the most
convincing case because I had read a lot
of sort of the Christian apologetics
books and I don't want to get too too
too into the details here but what
really convinced me was when I started
reading the antique Christian yeah
writings of early Christians yeah and
they all accepted the idea that Jesus
Christ was that you can read these right
now you'd probably know the names better
than because our bento cathetus a long
time haven't brushed up on this at all
but we should have but they all accepted
that Jesus Christ was a person yeah they
really had as great historical impactful
accounts and there was this resurrection
but here's why it doesn't matter that
much the easiest thing to do would have
been an early Christian to brought out
Jesus's body the easiest to do would've
been like well actually it's a hoax
there was no resurrection the fact that
people were arguing against this
exploding faith trying to quell it yeah
saying all that happened but this is why
it doesn't matter to the degree that you
think it matters for me was very
convincing right in tandem with the rest
of the historical context and in tandem
with archaeological discoveries that
we've had I mean a big one was the
kingdom of David we've talked about this
yeah I think rhett and Link say this in
their thing as well you know the fact
that there was no evidence of the Exodus
which is just just inaccurate it's not
right not right but for the longest time
up until I don't remember the year when
they discovered the slab and then more
evidence about the kingdom of David
people often argued against the Bible
and say well you know what the biggest
case is if we're going to talk about
historical evidence David this crazy
ruler of this kingdom thing and then
there was yeah yeah and then they and
then they've since doesn't mean that you
won't find it eventually that's not
proof positive that it means that it's
real but it is something to keep in mind
when you're making arguments that can be
very temporary and I think that
rhettandlink do that quite a bit and
again I say this out of love but I just
don't think the arguments they make cut
the mustard this is another one that is
very common we see it among all sort of
SJW woke left it's not saying that they
are that then we have another clip to
get to that but this idea of sort of
situational ethics or moral relativism
let's go to the clip I think the point
is is I don't think you wake up and make
decisions to be a good person because
you've got this moral lawgiver
there may be a moral lawgiver I do
saying that God doesn't exist yeah where
else does that come from but I think
that it's a much more natural and
organic process then there's a book I
read it and now I know what to do I
think that's why those core qualities of
what makes a human good exist in
cultures everywhere you find a culture
in the middle of the Amazon that's never
been exposed to the gospel or any sort
of religious system outside of what they
believe they're gonna think that
murdering is great probably not actually
they do Hemi rabbi or Hammurabi you know
Moses to tell them well you know what
you can also go down the base just just
go down a few Amazon basin blocks I
guess yeah fine tribesmen who are
munching on some guy's testicles like
it's a snack pack
a human sacrifice heads up let's go to
your Cancun break in between between
booze cruise stops and go check out the
Mayan ruins where they would kill small
children yeah this idea that morality is
universal no it's not and I can tell you
that certainly for me MIT and I know
this is an argument you hear from people
like Hitchens and Dawkins well then
here's a horrible person if you need God
to tell you not to do those things well
hold on a second I don't need God to
tell me not to murder maybe I do because
I grew up in a modern Christian society
Western civilization where we are told
not to murder and by the way that's not
the same everywhere the same thing with
theft right or I grew up in a society
that says don't abuse women Western
civilization we created domestic abuse
laws in Islam and Islamic nations they
call that laughable right this is a
different people have different beliefs
these come to different conclusions of
morality
I need the Bible to tell me that I
shouldn't be a philanderer right because
there are plenty of societies where you
can sleep with as many people as you
want you can be a polygamist you can
have or in Islamic societies or you can
have child brides the list goes in your
state of California you think that it is
stigmatizing for people to have to
disclose their AIDS when they have sex
with somebody everywhere else in the
country we say that's a common courtesy
that it's universal
no you can't just take the extremes of
murder right you have to look at mercy
yeah there's no out they didn't say
Alexander the merciful because that
would be how exactly the right mercy
does not a very few until modern
Christendom it's still not a value in
much of the third world or non Western
civilization's yeah it just shows me
that you know to make a comment like
that I mean it's very it's wishful like
you're hoping that there's everybody
throughout cultures throughout history
and that's just not proven to be the
case like if you study history at all
what you see is that left to our own
devices we're very evil and evil tends
to manifest itself in selfishness
inherently good look right now right we
have PTIN so people would be like well
this is this evil or not well it's
selfish right everybody hears that
there's a toilet paper shortage and then
go and buy every single piece of frickin
toilet paper they can find and they have
two rooms full and their neighbor has
none right now that's the kind of
condition humans tend to exist in we've
only recently gotten to a place where we
don't kill
each other on site okay give us a minute
it's not goodness and culture throughout
the world and throughout history at all
and you will find that out if you just
do a curse I'm actually pretty glad
because I used to know I was on YouTube
back in 2006 and it was a sort of wave
of atheists where they knew a common
saying if God is real why do all these
horrible things happen to good people
why does he allow these things happen
and then of course I don't need a god to
tell me not to kill someone right and
these have been debunked since sort of a
modern wave of people aren't even
necessarily Christians but Christians
sympathises and sort of the new right I
guess conservatives libertarians all
these people who understand the value of
Western civilization how it was spawned
by Christendom because yeah these shared
values have created what we know and
love and it's it's widely accepted it's
been debunked this idea that morality is
the same across culture so this is a
frankly very rudimentary but I guess it
works in California and and
technological advancement is something
we're talking about earlier and
technological advancement is moral good
it actually it being resourceful looking
at the things around you and making
things making new stuff that makes
people's lives better right that is a
moral positive so it's it's not it's not
like there's morality over here in
scientific advancement over here right
those things go together so a society
that has scientific advancement and
moral advancement is a better society
right no I think you're absolutely right
and I think that's how you end up
getting backwards when you have things
like communism or you have things like
socialist yeah it's not even later what
hold on a second we've we've separated
economics and morality well now let's
bring morality into economics because
the moral thing to do would be to
redistribute this from on a second the
problem with this is that you haven't
applied for example from the get-go a
moral view or application to use of
money the Bible is clear about that the
biblical application to money is first
don't steal it I don't care if you give
it to the Salvation Army
you stole it first you can't do that
that's in kind of the top ten yeah don't
do that right and that's how you realize
or you avoid this idea of socialism God
originally yeah yeah no exactly but also
they get rid of the you know socialism
in countries that kind of work off of
those systems they get rid of individual
value which is which is espouse
throughout the Bible right thou shalt
not steal assumes that somebody has
something that's not yours it
Institute's personal property rights
right there yeah shalt not kill it by
the way so didn't there live I'm not
yours
that many Native American tribes didn't
have a concept uh no no I'm not saying
here's the thing I'm not saying that
that's right or wrong I'm not saying the
fact that effectively Manhattan was
purchased for was a ship's guild
something guilders I don't remember as
they put ones like seven thousand beaver
pelts worth a nice I don't have these no
we weren't the nicest they just thought
a lot of these people these uh were the
Canarsie if I'm not mistaken someone can
fact check they don't have this in front
of me I believe they're like well yeah
we'll still on this Manhattan it's hard
to get to if to get in the canoe to get
there yeah and plus if they take like we
miss it now you may think one is right
and one is wrong but that shows you that
this this understanding of morality was
not Universal the idea of personal
property that is something that yeah
that Christians believe into a modern
value right right that that was the the
cornerstone of Christianity and and
really just the God of the Bible is that
every individual is valuable and unique
and has rights that are given to them by
God their creator right and it's not
it's not the hole that you're looking at
as if the whole thing is Stalin s
collective exactly but the cool thing is
it doesn't it doesn't get rid of the
need to care for the whole - it also
addresses taking care of the widow's the
orphans and and the poor right and
taking care of people that have been
disenfranchised like it takes care of
all of that and they claim that it does
not so anyway sorry was kind of a side
point but I thought it was worth making
no I think I think it's worth making as
well is there anything else that we had
to hit their way okay all right and
that's this is where we kind of get to
the a lot of people out there hopefully
you know we do this obviously mug club
behind the paywall for people who are
paying members because there's more
buying this is difficult to have this
conversation and sometimes we'll do an
ongoing series of mass Mondays so use
the promo code quarantine to get your
very steep discount yes but this is
something that a lot of people may not
understand who aren't Christians out
there I think that a lot of atheists
think that Christians exist in this
monolith like we're all you know the mom
from Kerry where you know we have civil
war and are in our bosom by the end of
the film
I this has been creeping into the
Christian Church for a long time the
social justice sort of leftism and
that's because unfortunately they've
been trying to water it down and I don't
mean necessarily what again frankly
strip elements of the faith that are
pretty important to make it palatable to
places like California so that people
don't get hurt feelings which is why if
there's nothing else that you take from
this it is that your the experiential
cannot trump understanding why you
believe what it is that you believe you
need to have a reasoned basis in your
faith you need to understand Scripture
you need to understand and be able to
articulate and defend your beliefs or
you have no business espousing them so
that being said this is sort of
indicative of what we've been talking
about this is it's not just Christian
conservatives and SJW left a huge
portion of the church I would wager
probably most members of churches in
Southern California at the very least in
my experience are a part of that
amalgamin of the social justice warrior
left now
Kayson just play it so I don't it's
gonna hurt so many women and so many
people who don't fit the mold and we
talked about like the LGBTQ Q+
experience of people how dare you plow
them in the church a lot of there's a
lot of stories of trauma because as
people were sort of developing their
identity and self actualizing they were
doing it in an oppressive it don't know
what that means
that's damages law but again california
talk because of who I am and what I look
like I pretty much just benefited and so
I don't look back at my experience with
the church in a traumatic way we've
heard enough those stories right to know
that it's it's a nightmare it's much
more of a nightmare than what we
experience which was extreme privilege
yeah one of things we talked about is we
just benefited from the system I mean
you know look at the leadership in the
evangelical church and it's very male
very white and very straight you know
into a black church I'm gonna yeah I
went to an Ethiopian Church its Angeles
and I went to a church in Jamaica Queens
where they actually came in canvass for
a local congressional candidate because
they don't really care about the 501 C 3
C 4 yeah
Farrakhan exercise all say mean in not
insulting people because I obviously
want there are a lot of insults that
that I want to make not only about that
but but the host was fit for everyone
but I'm just gonna try and be a state
yeah that's my my point is that's my
baggage that is your cross to bear right
this minute
I mean first off the hairdos let me get
okay I'm not saying it because he looks
like a gay European soccer player bear
what I am saying right is that if you
look at and this is so for people out
there please please listen the
Christians out there please don't be
afraid to comment this and feel like
you're letting them in the other team
settle the truth is the hairdos that
they had when they started on YouTube or
the exact hairdos that you would expect
a youth pastor to have in that era yeah
kind of blink-182 but really listen MxPx
are your parents don't get mad and you
have the bangs and then all of a sudden
it switches to now the trimmed on the
sides and high on the top in the middle
and then it'll probably switch to a
reverse like the original terminator
where the bangs will be really short
enough someone at the point is their
values in Silicon Valley and apparently
from are just as cyclical as the styles
and if you look at the kind of content
to that comes from rhett and link where
you can describe and they describe it as
brand friendly you can describe the
entire I guess sort of mission statement
of the content of rhett and Link is
brand friendly YouTube chen's chasing
yes it's what worked in UTM 1 or 2009
that's what they did what do they think
was gonna be working in YouTube in 2014
that's what they did that's the style a
video that's the style they dress that's
how they try to appeal to people
milquetoast go-along get-along
and and that's what bothers when you see
that a lot with with people sometimes
who are Christians where they changed
their values as often as their style
that's the problem trendy yeah and one
of the things he said about traumatic
experiences for a lot of people and that
they didn't necessarily experience that
same kind of issue because they were
straight white men in the church you
look there there are plenty there
there's a lot that we have to own as
Christians right and because sometimes
our brothers and sisters do and say
things that we've made
much disagree with inhibition and we
look very beneficial as well as victims
yeah a lot of Christians killed in the
Aguada a lot so what I would say is that
look II I understand that that happens
that does not change what truth is well
huh I don't wanna this sort of like
Jordan Peterson same here so truth is I
want to go to the these are specifics
they say women are welcome at the church
we don't could claim sanctuary by the
way yeah they were allowed to come thank
you very for a long women are very well
treated at the church now if you yeah
and this is something that's also
important if you mean to say that is
offensive for a church to believe in
traditionalist roles if you believe it
is sexist to have expectations of women
in the church just as they have of men
in other words they have expectations of
accountability of transparency from men
in positions of leadership right they
have small groups they have a board of
elders and they expect women to also
serve in the church there are
expectations of both men and women and
yeah this is definitely true the
Christian faith does not see men and
women is fundamentally interchangeable
we do believe going back to your point
that they are then unique intrinsically
fearfully and wonderfully created and so
we believe in complementarianism I get
that's offensive today but it's not
because we hate women if you look at
Jesus and his preaching yeah the first
feminists the guy was hanging around
with women they didn't do that back then
and they were included in a lot of
things that they never would have been
included in any other writings around
the time there's no way that they would
have been featured in some of those
things and so yeah one of the one of the
points that I was gonna make is okay
well let's let's take out hot-button
issues right let's take out the the
feminist stuff let's take out the lgbtq+
move and I'm gonna take all of those no
that's what he says right those are the
hot-button issues I'm gonna take those
out though let me let me put let me put
it this way if I want to call your songs
of Solomon his wife is spicy when she
talks to them in front of us on my home
we're still here yeah yes exactly dry so
let me let me put it what if I what if I
walked into a church what if I walked
into their church like their ideal
Church what the response
what would the response be if I said
well look guys I'm just I'm a serial
liar like I do
right care about lying I think it's okay
to lie all the time and and I really
don't like are you going to confront me
with truth and this is where I was going
are you gonna confront me with truth and
say well look God says not I believe I
believe is not a precise way of saying
it because your beliefs can be wrong God
says is much more precise and I can
point to Scripture yeah
lying is wrong yeah it's not it's not me
you have a problem with its God if you
disagree with that and wait I want to
but there's a perfect example of Gerald
and I and I know I give Gerald a tough
time but Jill does someone have very
much trust he was a groomsman at my
wedding and we've we've talked about
these issues quite a quite a bit and I'm
willing to bet substantially more than
about the son we were outside the patio
outside of a Chili's yes and you were
talking about how at that point I don't
want to say we talked about this yeah we
can talk about this how you were you
were you were you were you were I was
acting I wasn't going like I was I was
earlier in the jail you know yeah well
no no I'm not like sleeping around that
was not what wasn't best thing like hey
man I'm having a problem I'm not being
the person that I want to be and this is
what's going on and you're like well
stop being a dick I said like I love you
and I think that listen you need to be
consider be consistent we have values
you know this is wrong you know that you
and I said I told you I wouldn't say
this if you were an atheist because it
wouldn't matter no tell me this because
it matters to you and because I love you
I think you need to live this way or
you're not gonna find the woman that you
want right you're just gonna find [ __ ]
yeah because they think that's naughty
language but that was a it worked
no it helped you you come at me with
truth right and the wounds of a friend
right essentially is what scripture
talks about like you were very careful
in how you did that but you'd let me
know based on who you said you want to
be this doesn't line up and by the way
this doesn't line up with what scripture
says right like you need to understand
that if you go down this path that's not
who you want to be and that's not who
God has called you to be if you can't
correct and love then there hasn't ever
been a single loving parent who s you
disciplinary action exactly yeah right
so I won yeah and he mentioned
specifically like what I look like so we
talked about straight white male so what
I think a soccer paper yeah
though he does look like it's just a
joke it's renowned salvation yes yeah so
real under making observations that
Philip DeFranco has gone in his entire
life to the barber and said give me the
child number two so yeah so you
mentioned whiteness so is if there's
some kind of hierarchy in Christianity
like I mean yes there is racism in
everywhere who called themselves
Christians but before Christianity I
mean white people were sacrificing each
other to trees this is really kind of
inherent hierarchy and enslaving other
white people black people also slave
black people yeah non-christians and
Christians alike yeah yeah doesn't mean
that it's necessarily consistent with
their values yeah this idea and again
this idea that somehow you are less
qualified to speak on an issue or that
God expects you to shut up because of
your skin color that is not biblical
right that is a California
indoctrination
and it almost might as well be the book
of Southern California the book of the
entertainment entry the book of the woke
left because it is race is race
determines someone's identity more than
their faith which is what they are
saying it is both and for Christians who
get mad that I say both it matters more
that we get through the [ __ ]
well look it's literally specify what is
[ __ ] yeah that's true it is but to
say that someone's I cannot be like I
want to make sure this is crystal clear
to imply that somebody's race ethnicity
gender or sexual orientation defines
their identity more than their values
he's [ __ ] yeah it absolutely is and
you know they're talking about like this
loving experience like these traumatic
experience is kind of quickly going back
to that if if you know a Penn & Teller
right who's the guy that talks up the -
I can't remember I always forget isn't
Penn so Penn actually you can YouTube
this he actually said look if you
believe what you say you believe
Christians like if God is real and there
is a heaven and a hell because it'd be
like somebody's standing out in the
middle of the highway and you seeing a
truck coming at them and you don't warn
you this I hate to get out of the West
he was saying when people sort of try
and
yeah actually appreciate a theist yeah
kinda nobly yeah exactly he's saying so
so what is more loving if somebody who
is gay or somebody who's a liar who
somebody who the God has said hey this
is sin comes and says hey these are the
things that I do is it more loving to
say Oh God doesn't care no no it's
totally fine or is it to say hey let's
talk about what God has called you to
here right what's the more loving thing
to do and in culture we think the more
loving thing to do is just to accept
everybody the way that they are and say
that there is no truth for us to look at
and say well what does God say what does
God say about how this will work best
for all yeah so it really does come down
to who you trust do you trust the
culture who says right be nice to
everybody or treat everybody and you
know be nice at least with that kind of
definition right or do you trust God do
you trust the experts with the all the
degrees or do you trust God you trust
the culture that you're living in that
might have some kind of particular
milieu it's in their standards are
constantly shifting and say even if you
don't believe even if you don't believe
in God let's just take them as
archetypes because a lot of times they
left they try to act as though there
isn't some kind of an archetype so let's
just say Jordan Peterson was talking
about this it was tough for me to
understand if he really believes that
Jesus is a true person in God or the
Bible right literally to shorten it
right now the archetype of that God well
the archetype of the left what they are
talking about now what this these people
worship effectively in the entertainment
industry is the archetype of the perfect
woke entirely enlightened inoffensive
social justice warrior leftist that is
the other type the archetype is someone
who uses all the right acronyms who
includes everybody who supports
diversity quotas when really there
should be some kind of a financial
bailout to help with a growing virus
pandemic the archetype there is this is
the perfect this is the ideal even if
you say that you don't believe in a God
or you don't believe in any scripture
you still do have an idea as to what is
right because if you don't believe there
is a right and wrong then this doesn't
apply to you but if you believe that
there's right and wrong at all that does
mean that somewhere down the line if you
question it long enough there is an
ideal that's what's right yeah that's
the thing that guide your life and in
this case it's something that moves with
culture and that's not that you need an
anchor to guide you if you're gonna have
an archetype make it something that does
not change right right and having it
be the cultural whims of him heard they
write babies because culture like
culture daily suck culture is
transformers and it ruins people just
look at 80s era David Bowie
but that crystallised him at the worst
point in career or Elvis in Vegas I
don't know why the Elvis impersonators
go out with the stupid Vegas rhinestone
strewth Elvis mahjong was the most
beautiful man to have ever walked the
face of the earth t-shirt and jeans his
hair slicked back he did a few curls
he'd go around imitator decides to grow
a potbelly and sunglasses rhinestones in
a cape and impersonate him at the worst
point is career Ultron could be the most
corrosive yeah humanity's all right very
true let's move on to the next clip I
guess you sort of in this whatever it is
that we're that we are right now I call
myself a hopeful agnostic right now but
I don't know ideas structure or the
community or the singular sort of
well-defined purpose that I did and that
is that's a problem listen it's not like
I'm about to give you some philosophy
that I live according to now that's got
get the gives that gives me community
purpose and meaning I don't have that
okay I think there's a giant sort of
shift that's happening culturally and I
think that we may be arriving at that
sometime but it doesn't exist right now
for me but what does exist is an
openness is this curiosity so why I'd
yeah I don't know what you know does
anyone want to say then that seems
really sad yeah hopefully I'll get it to
get to it I jumped into the water took
my wife and children what he said
earlier and I don't have it
guiding his wife is his children and his
whole audience now yeah yeah well in
does he really think that what we're
headed to in our culture is more unity
more purpose right without like yeah it
we're in this huge shift culturally who
might be arriving at a replacement for
the church yeah like the purpose that
guiding everything it's it really has
shown that husband yes I would
yeah he's shown that he's essentially
replaced an old thing with yes trying to
build a new utopia and that's his new
religion right at least hoping that
somebody's also the danger of organize
and plant centralized planning from a
government because that's a big reason
when you look at stalinistic when you
look at calm I'm saying stone the
Atheist idea because it's this idea that
the collective is more important than
the individual Christianity we do not
believe that you may find some
Christians who said they do sorry
they're incorrect I don't have time to
get into it right now we're already 50
minutes in that was no your honor the
defense is wrong okay so they don't not
really in the power of the individual
over the collective and they believe
that is the government's job to
centrally-planned these communities so
that people find purpose through what
now nothing more than community culture
and what the government has devised for
them and that's why it was so important
that they would shut down churches and
literally nail the door shut when people
say that religion has killed more people
than anything else throughout the
history of mankind first off a lot of
these religious wars were fought over
territory they were fought over all
kinds of reasons where you happen to
have people from different religious
world views on either side but you'd
have to look at just the regimes in
China and Russia 100 million people it's
not even close yeah not even close and
this is one of the most sad things that
he says to me because it's not like I
would I think I would understand a
little bit more of his story if he says
I've looked into these 15 world
religions there are plenty of suitors
for you to come there's plenty of people
that want you to come to their church of
the now right there's plenty of things
that you can go out there and join
Oprah's thing or you can join whatever
so you got a lot of options in telling
names the guy with the glass eye yeah
you're telling me that none of those
things like you're a hopeful egg not
what it what does that mean does that
mean you're a lazy agnostic because if
you're hopeful that somebody's going to
bring the knowledge to you you're never
gonna get anything right so if you're
just sitting there waiting for it to
show up on your front porch from UPS
it's not gonna happen
that means hopeful like not and mean you
must hate your agnostic conservative Oh
meaning that you think like I'm hoping
that kind of liberal yeah well and where
doesn't it right where does the Hope
come from one right the hope for right
and he says at some point that he is
gonna follow truth wherever it leads
well how will he judge between what's
true and what isn't true right
he dropped his whole standard it's got
no doesn't have any objective standard
he just has his whims right right so he
said something so important that's why I
will say yeah and I want to go right go
back I want to go back to your point
there but that's why it's so important
to get back to the idea of there's
universal right and wrong yes we talked
about the women that is it and I love I
love that that is so easy to discredit
and I love that so many people who are
not Christians recognize the value of
Western civilization right now that's
sort of been this awakening of Donald
Trump in this populism people who
weren't Christians but they go you know
what I see the difference we now send
the Islamic world I see the difference
between us and even even continents like
Africa you see what goes on there and
the idea of Western European American
civilization and our values because
values are not universal and if you
understand that and if you are able to
point out that moral relativism does not
work that there isn't a universal good
and we have to live in a society that
agrees upon that nothing else that
rhettandlink can possibly stand yeah and
I think that's why it's so important it
will wat why do you believe there's a
universal right and wrong yeah poke
those holes yeah absolutely he said
something earlier on in the video like
this just resonated with me right you
know now that was a bad thing it's not
that it's not that one thankfully
different from well two shorts were that
was just three oh this was always like
nice gams nice very nice Crescent and oh
let me let me just make a quick point
about that your religion is not based on
your feeling right being a Christian
believing in God is not based on your
feelings about this right right it's
really irrelevant like your feelings
like oh it resonates or it doesn't
resonate like truth cannot resonate
sometimes with you because it's hard
because you don't necessarily want to
change how selfish you've been to get
around it the first time I used a wet
wipe
ya know into the bathroom I realize that
no one considered all the time your
underwear to the person dry wet and dry
again they live by but so I worked in a
ministry and it was the new believers
basically so if you raised your hand you
walk down you said the prayer we would
we would have you come back to a room
and we talked to you for a minute just
to say hey like hey you know great we're
so
I did for you but we would ask a
question that would always become very
telling to me over time how many of you
is this your first time
you know committing your life to Christ
and we would get probably 25% of the
hands 30% of the hands would go up and
that meant the rest of the room had made
an emotional decision at some point they
felt a moment they had the worship was
great the pastor was speaking the way
that they wanted something inspired them
to come down and now they feel like they
have to do it again and then they feel
like they have to do it again and we
started seeing frequent flyers and I'm
like man and I'm not picking on those
people I'm not saying that it's not okay
to like reaffirm your faith and say you
know what I have been wondering and I
want to come back and really get back
into this because I've been doing the
wrong thing I'm saying that people think
that it's this feeling they're missing
it like if you once you get introduced
to Jesus and ask him into your heart
that's done like you don't have to be
reintroduced right you know what I mean
you don't have to recommit your life to
Christ you've done that already you just
have to stop acting like a fool right
right come back and repent then it comes
down to your actions at the find it's
like when you fall in love with someone
listen this is something that a lot of
women don't like to hear at some point
every man who loves you more than more
than the earth itself is going to fall
out of that feeling of love with you if
only temporarily it happens there are
times when you get into a foot when you
get into a fight with your wife or your
husband that's why the Bible is
prescriptive and it's a program love
being an action yes it talks about it
again love which is a thing right this
is and we can we can scientifically sort
of observe that where you can talk about
neurotransmitters and double mean and
all this stuff going on fine but that
because that is temporary because that
is fleeting the Christian worldview of
love is that of an action and that is
why we are against divorce
whereas in Islam a man can say to like
like three times and he's divorced the
woman has no recourse that's true that's
why you have a lot of not without my
daughter an abducted is my children
because there are their rights and the
women do not we don't believe in love as
a feeling we believe in love as an
initial feeling and then in action and
the same thing should be your faith
because I think I honestly I've had
maybe two times in my life a deeply
spiritual experience yeah emotional love
yeah twice and one of them was very
recent their formative um and the rest
has been a battle of the mind yeah and I
think a lot and there are some
Christians out there who may you may not
struggle with that some Christians they
you know they have that that faith of a
child that's that nothing can tear you
away from
and that's beautiful and it's wonderful
but that's not that's not most of us and
that's okay because the battle taking
place in your mind that is expected
that's why we have the scripture yeah
that's why the Bible talks about doubts
that's why the Bible talks about faith
that's why the Bible is prescriptive and
how you should approach your marriage
how I should approach your finances how
you should approach your business all of
these things because it understands that
we are human beings who live in a very
physical world
yeah with tangible decisions that have
to be made all right we have did you
know something else they want to so I'm
just gonna say that it and that's why
it's important to have a baseline level
of trust through all of the doubts
through all the confusion and things
like that having a baseline trust in God
even through the questions right is the
only way to go and question surged in
the Bible acts 17:11 actually makes a
point that like these guys are better
than these guys right I'll let you go
rebury ins basically better than the
these'll and I can sing these guys heard
it and received the word they were ready
for and that's tough to be ready for in
the first place
but then they search scripture to see if
it was true that's they were lauded for
that like go out and question and see if
this is true based on what scripture
says go and test this right god you're
right says don't don't test me in some
of these ways but he does say test me in
this test me in tithing
alright that's very easy and search the
scriptures to see if what you're hearing
is true if what the culture says is true
what your priest says is true my
goodness sometimes people can be wrong
it's not saying don't trust anybody but
it's saying hey receive it trust it but
then go and make sure that it lines up
with what I have told you is true and by
the way for those of you out there may
be listening and saying man that seems
like a really high bar not to like this
feeling of love and sometimes you're not
gonna love God made it very clear that
that's exactly what he did for us right
he said that Christ died while you were
yet sinners and there was nothing about
you that was neat like that I should
like and want to redeem like your
actions weren't worn to be a context you
getting a little grandiose so what
you're correct to put it in context walk
into your nearest jack-in-the-box
or Waffle House whoever pass whole thing
out pick the worst representative Jack
in the Box mister Waffle House would you
be willing to be kicked in the nuts for
that guy Rhett could be a girl probably
yeah that's what Christ did for you only
he was killed
yeah yeah he knew the worst
jack-in-the-box customer that ever
existed and the worst person of Walmart
I'm going to be crucified for that guy
yeah
that's pretty tough to do before they
dose and that matters a whole lot more
than somebody using the proper pronouns
in California I'm sorry you can it's not
the same level of suffering especially
when you know Aaron at jack-in-the-box
screw that guy don't like what he does
it's too late for rhett and Link mostly
because of this LGBT thing once they've
gone there it's too late for them and
I'm like can't you see that you guys
have lost this argument the history is
going to leave you behind
the thing that we're finding out right
now and it's one of the key reasons that
so many people are leaving the church is
that that tension can only lead to the
tension being broken you know and I
think the way it's gonna be broken is
that I'm just like I said earlier so
many different issues that the church
has held out on I mean even have the
most conservative denominations a
hundred years from now no no one except
these like a fringe cult is gonna be
anti LGBT in a hundred years it's just
if you just look at history and the way
things progressed culturally eventually
the church says okay we'll incorporate
that too because if we don't we're going
to die really but I think because the
church is being really slow to do that
and it's kind of causing existential
crisis and a crisis of just the way that
they see the Bible and the young people
are just saying I'm out I'm not gonna be
a part of okay so a couple of points
here's very clear the hang-up is the
LGBT for them and that's based again on
a false premise that if you are a
Christian that you can't hug Michael
Buckley that you hate yeah by the way
back then it was still parallel GB that
you have to hate algae but good owners
that's not true as a matter of fact it's
the opposite
yeah our faith informs you are of course
supposed to love them and you can have
disagreements with people and we can
talk about sin which they try and cut
off with the past too and say love the
sinner hate the sin that's a really
silly statement I also have a problem
there's a his analogy there about
there's nothing that can happen to the
tension other than break that's not you
ever hear of a pulley yeah
you're using the tension to pull up the
bucket
I saw Swiss Family Robinson break and by
the way this is a danger when you talk
about there's this mass exodus I don't
have the sources in front of it actually
the United States there's there's
actually kind of resurgence of
Christendom with a lot of young people
but for sure beyond any shadow of a
doubt what was your name the lesbian
who's just on the show Arielle Scarcella
this up and I think we have an overlay
from USA Today that for the first time
in several decades the young young
Americans they have a more negative view
of the LGBTQ community than people who
come before them so those eyes are
turning so you don't want all of your
all of your fundamental principles to
rest on everyone else is doing it yeah
because guess what that can change and
unfortunately for you it's actually
changing right now where there's an
existential crisis for lesbians on the
left yeah lesbians are getting
aggravated with lesbians just like by
the way this could have been used at one
point to convert people to Christianity
certainly was used to convert people to
Islam by force as opposed to
word-of-mouth was everybody else is
doing it with Islam it was everybody
else is doing it or they were sharpening
it exactly it doesn't mean that it's
right that's one of the most logical
fallacies there is what are the so I'm
just I'm baffled by this if this is the
the crux like in a hundred years none of
these churches are gonna say oh we'll
just incorporate how do you incorporate
it without changing the Word of God in
several clearly-defined like what pages
are you gonna rip out of your new Bible
because you can't leave Romans in you
can't leave Leviticus in you can't leave
other parts of the Bible and that are
very very clear they really want that to
change in the church this is I'm gonna
talked about and Dave Rudin was
surprised and so i don't support gay
marriage I said I support gay civil
union I think that church churches
should be involved in marriage I don't
think the federal government should be
involved in marriage right
is there another clip I'm seeing on
there was I don't know what that means I
said I don't think so David Rubin was
surprised yeah and I wasn't because I
don't believe that men and women are
fundamentally interchangeable this was
before the whole TV part was sort of
tagged on right and I don't know to the
point you were saying something and then
I saw this thing that you didn't see
they kind of distracted you a little bit
but I so the assumption is that that sin
means that you can't be cordial to
somebody you can't love somebody you
can't incorporate you can't say look I
understand you have a right to go be a
sinner right God God gave you the
freedom to choose to not pick him
okay alright so they're saying that at
some point we're just gonna say well
this is the hot button I said it again
dammit this is the issue of today right
the LGBT issue because you're gonna go
back and do it again you're gonna call
me the the Soliman thing whatever yeah I
should have just kept going but this is
the what is the next one we're just
gonna pick another part of the Bible and
say well we don't really agree with that
become what do you believe right here's
what they believe this is what it comes
down to we become our own gods right it
sells up to us whatever we choose to do
get away from you get away from me get
away get away get thee behind me Satan
all right
no I mean it really is that's that's
essentially what I call zero
I appreciate it give me something hotter
ghost pepper do that no hybridize but no
the point I was making is when I say
this about the gate about the LGBTQ
thing is because they've desperately
tried to thrust that upon the church and
this is about Dave Rubin I said you have
this in Canada where if a pastor says
I'm not going to marry two guys Stephen
well son was one of the press you can be
jailed now that being said people
haven't really argued before because men
now cohabitate men and women like they
live together before they're married
that's not relatively new when you take
into consideration sort of shacking up
Western civilized by the way shocks me
when someone calls in a doctor Laura and
like I'm living with my boyfriend and so
but they've never Society changed but
they never really tried to thrust that
upon the church right well people are
living together and you don't do it
you're traditionalists but the same-sex
marriage thing was something tried to
thrust upon the church because of this
worldview that men and women are
fundamentally different and I'm not
talking about the entire gay community
I'm talking about those who are the sort
of Gestapo LGBT a few Nazis who by the
way now aggravate lesbians and gay
people on the Left who just want to live
and let live and that's why they've
really tried to thrust it into the
church because it pulls at the thread of
that if they can they can get a foothold
saying well no ha a second let's
actually hate speech to say that men and
women are different right and then a man
in a man is not the same
in the eyes of God as a man and a woman
but the church needs to stand strong and
say well in the church it's not yeah
this is a can say sure but the church
doesn't yeah and Christians should
recognize that there's a play being run
on them and that's the play the play is
niceness right play is there they're
taking advantage of our willingness to
sort of go okay yeah that's fine and
just keep retreating and they're using
that again to gain the upper hand in the
culture gather so that the so that the
left-wing like you said the sort of
totalitarian minded people have this
inherent impulse and that's to try to
keep people down let me said you said
without using the n-word because that's
in my car with the windows rolled up at
least a thousand times it's hard it's
hard I saw it in your eyes
[Laughter]
have you ever used the n-word yeah I'm
just like I'm a huge hip-hop fan I have
a Bluetooth speaker in the shower
[Laughter]
context matter because I'm in Wi do you
want to go through the list and more
technique do you want me to I mean what
yeah you know I want to hear how much
people whether you're Christian whether
you're not this is the kind of stuff
that's available in Month Club tomorrow
we will have I think more of a standard
yes Sanders show like you come to know
on Thursday sometimes I do a scrap here
where we take all the crap that was too
offensive to make a show the reason we
do is because the cart is often the
photo shops are too offensive so we just
have smooth Manny from Colombia just do
them as cartoons show that you've come
to know and expect and of course morning
drive good morning mug club check the
schedule available at us credit come I
think what's most important here is
first off I would I would gladly host
Rhett link Phil DeFranco yeah doesn't
come from none of this comes from a
place of hate it comes from a place of
love and wanting what's best for people
and listen I would be remiss if I didn't
tell people that yeah I think what is
best for everybody man woman child gay
straight is to have a personal
relationship with God and what Laura I
call them good guy God Jesus I think
that matters and I will take this when
people say what I just do it because God
told me to no not always but if anyone
here maybe you don't need to but I
certainly would acknowledge it in my
moments of weakness that I've had where
it's particularly someone who struggle
with depression understand that is that
is a safeguard that is a guardrail of
you know what actually I was designed
for a purpose
yeah and I do think and I have known a
lot of Christians who've also struggle
with suicidal thoughts or tendencies and
thought you know what haunting I don't
have the right to do that because this
really isn't my body and so it may not
be of value to you in Southern
California but it is to a lot of people
and I think that particularly for me in
moments of weakness where maybe I don't
have the answer having that trust that
okay this is you know what I don't
necessarily know each action each
individual step but I do know the
prescription for what I need to do to
achieve what is morally right and a look
at Scripture and that helps we make
decisions when sometimes decisions are
tough to make the only way though that
this faith can stand and I think we can
talk about this this happens by the way
also with Christians who are just like
you said running a game the nice
Christian yeah who are open to all I
mean as someone said this this is not my
own original quote I don't know who said
it so please don't get mad at me for not
attributing this to you they say listen
you cannot continually water down the
message of of Christ and the value you
can't continually water down the
medicine and then be shocked when it
doesn't work yeah
when someone turns to it for answers and
they don't have them and so everyone out
there even if you've grown up as a
Christian your whole life I have people
say grow up you always have to choose to
follow Christ no one really is it no one
is just raised Christian you'll be
raised in that culturally but culture
use to make a decision every single
person does but even if you've been
raised with that you've never had a
crisis of faith you need
to have it be based on a reason you need
to be able to reason your faith you need
to understand intellectually why it is
that you believe what you believe and
you need to be able to defend it I don't
mean go out and argue with everyone
because you're always going to find
someone who's more qualified than you to
argue but it has to be more than an
emotion otherwise you just become a
byproduct of your environment and then
you find yourself subjected to the whims
of moral relevancy and I don't think
you're gonna like the way that one ends
up yeah all right thank you guys very
much the promo code of course is
quarantine to get your steep discount we
will be back with you tomorrow with a
normal show show you've come to love
hope you enjoyed nice Monday let us know
[Music]